that night she tells NY that she's
feeling better than ever and she
famously Burns her tongue with the
lighter and watches it heal immediately
she even calls herself a God and starts
asking about need's boyfriend as if
she's interested devouring Jonas seems
to give her a huge boost and she appears
to be the only happy person in the
school though she at least seems to keep
a low enough profile for Jonas's funeral
earlier I mentioned that Jen's
cannibalistic Rampage is actually a
metaphor for her sleeping around we know
that she has insecurity problem so it's
obvious that she's using these
encounters to boost her self-esteem in a
literal sense her health is improved
because the consumption of human flesh
gives the demon power to sustain her but
what this really represents is her going
to bed with someone to boost her ego
feeling the emotional high that comes
with that for a little while then
sinking back into being miserable again
if she doesn't keep feeding the Demon's
hunger will always return this is a
temporary solution that never addresses
the root of the issue